bonjour laurent saint martin j'ai aussi
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes député la république en marge du
val de marne et vous êtes le rapporteur
général du budget à l'assemblée
nationale on va bien sûr longuement
parlé budget on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal jalabert
bonjour pascal bonjour du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on va parler budget évidemment
puisque c'est dans l'actualité laurent
saint martin le dernier budget du
quinquennat qui a donc été présenté
mercredi en conseil des ministres on l'a
vu dans les auditions qui ont commencé
notamment ici au sénat on en a parlé
budget
finalement avec plusieurs milliards de
dépenses augmentant bruno le maire dira
que le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est fini
quand on voit ce budget finalement c'est
pas fini le quoi qu'il en coûte le quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est la terminologie
qu'on a utilisées pour dire que
mettrions l'état tous les moyens
nécessaires pour sauver notre économie
pour sauver nos emplois et pour relancer
justement l'ensemble de notre appareil
productif
nous l'avons fait et maintenant que la
crise nous l'espérons tous et bien
derrière nous au moins ce qui concerne
ses conséquences économiques et sociales
alors effectivement il n'ya plus moyen
il n'y a plus de nécessité de poursuivre
l'activité partielle de poursuivre le
fonds de solidarité est prêt garanti par
l'état donc effectivement cela va
s'éteindre au fur et à mesure faut-il le
rappeler puisque certains secteurs sont
encore plus en souffrance que doc je
pense à l'automobile je pense à
l'aéronautique par exemple la hausse de
la dépense publique qui peut arriver sur
des politiques publiques prioritaires
tels que la sécurité la justice les
armées n'est rien d'autre que la
poursuite des lois castration dans
l'éducation par exemple et rien d'autre
pour la plupart que la poursuite et le
respect des lots programmation décidé il
ya plusieurs années et qui peut vraiment
dire qu'on n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui en
france de renforcer le salaire des
enseignants des soignants de mieux
investir dans la transition écologique
et puis de continuer encore une fois et
ça c'est très important
investir dans les technologies d'avenir
il va y avoir plusieurs milliards
d'euros qui vont être annoncées pour le
plan d'investissement france 2000 trans
et cela sera absolument fondamental pour
que nous ne sortions pas seulement de la
crise pas trop amochés mais que nous
ressortions de la crise franchement
renforcée
si vous assumez de dire oui on a un
budget de dépenses est ce que finalement
c'est pas un budget politique voire un
budget électoraliste que vous présentez
mais il fallait me dire ça au lendemain
de l'élection en 2010 est depuis cinq
ans nous sommes à l'action et nous
mettons des budgets en cohérence avec
nos actions regardez chaque ligne du
budget 2022 dites moi si ce n'est pas
une action prioritaire que nous avions
déjà annoncé depuis plus de quatre ans
renforcer la police et la gendarmerie
nous le faisons pendant que la droite
sous nicolas sarkozy l'avait
complètement dépecer renfoncer renforcer
la justice budget plus oui pour cent
nous faisons pendant que tous les
gouvernements précédents leur enlever
les moyens allez voir dans les
juridictions allez voir dans les
tribunaux s'ils ont pas besoin de moyens
l'hôpital public on peut pas nous dire
pendant des mois 18 mois de crise qu
vite que l'hôpital public est en
souffrance quand on fait un ségur de la
santé et quand mais enfin plusieurs
milliards de moyens et pour les
soignants et pour les moyens à l'hôpital
on nous dit ce qu'elle pense excusez moi
un moment il faut aussi que les paroles
sont en cohérence avec les actes nous
c'est le cas je suis pas là en effet
l'hôpital aux jeunes moyens l'école a
besoin de moyens la justice afghane
moyens ça veut dire qu'on est condamné à
dépenser plus dans les années à venir et
qu'il faut le dire aux français mais
comment le final ce tout ça ce débat est
un peu lunaire pas ici ce matin mais
depuis plusieurs jours la dépense
publique c'est pas un match entre des
plus et des moins la dépense publique
c'est un débat sur la nature de
l'investissement et comment
effectivement par d'autres aspects on
sait la réduire parce que on la
considère comme une efficiente de favre
déséquilibré tout ce que jésus
allégorique ce que vous dites reproche
l'opposition s'est passé mesures de
dépenses puisque évidemment tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
plus de moyens pour l'hôpital
de ne pas avoir de mesures d'économies
l'arrière les économies et la baisse de
la dépense publique au lendemain d'une
crise on a vu ce que ça a donné dans la
crise précédent de 2008 2009 c'est
l'austérité
résultat vous êtes obligés d'augmenter
les impôts juste après c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé à la fin du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy je pense
qu'il le regrette je pense que vous
devriez demander à la majorité
sénatoriale ci pense que c'était une
bonne réponse à la crise je suis à peu
près sûr que vous diront que non la
vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut
investir et baisser les impôts des
ménages ça marche ça crée de l'emploi et
justement ça redonne du pouvoir d'achat
nos concitoyens est ce que demain une
fois la crise passée sur un prochain
mandat ne faudra pas réformé pour
stabiliser puis réduire la dépense
publique là je dis oui là je dis oui à
commencer par la mère des réformes celle
que vous avez toujours à la bouche quand
je viens vous voir celle des retraites
il faudra la faire mais ce ne sera pas
la seule il y aura rien sur la réforme
des retraites notamment dans le dans le
budget de la sécurité sociale y aura
aucune mesure qui concerne la raconter
je ne suis pas ministre des solidarités
de la santé ce n'est pas moi qui vais
présenter ce budget mais je pense
qu'effectivement le temps n'est pas venu
de présenter aux français à travers le
parlement vous me disiez mais la réforme
des retraites il faut pas non plus at on
trop longtemps pour commencer à laon
plancher parce que celui des réformes de
deuxième mandat à l'éditeur deuxième
mandat je pense que sa mère lui même il
laissé entendre qu'il pourrait y avoir
des mesures dans le budget de la
sécurité sociale sur cette route demandé
mon avis sur une réforme systémique
clairement il n'est pas le temps du
dialogue social et du débat
parlementaire sur ce qu'on appelle
paramétrique ou sur des mesures
financières je pense que vous voyez bien
le débat est tellement épidermique sur
ce sujet que je crois que même sur les
sujets des équilibres financiers cela
demande à mon avis de le faire autour
d'un débat démocratique plus large qui
finalement au mieux l'élection
présidentielle ont pour vous l'heure
n'est pas venue avant là donc c'est le
sujet lui d'un éventuel second 15
septembre c'est un des sujets de la
compagnie sur les pas ce que vous nous
dites
ce qui a été fait en 2008 en bo1 ce qui
a été fait en 2008 c'est parce qu'il
fallait faire nous on va faire
différemment ça veut dire que ce matin
je dis clairement le moment des
économies n'est pas venu pour le moment
les règles budgétaires et le respect des
règles budgétaires on n'en parle plus
c'est pas pour tout de suite le respect
des règles budgétaires européennes si
c'est celle dont vous parlez nous sont
respectées par aucun pays européen nous
sommes dans un cadre macroéconomique
complètement caduque à ce niveau là donc
le sujet n'est pas de savoir s'il faut
le régler à l'automne ou pas nous avons
un endettement de 120% de piles dont je
rappelle que les 100%
quand nous sommes arrivés n'était pas
franchement de notre fait et aujourd'hui
le cadre européen c'est 60% n'arrivera
jamais à 60 % d'endettement public dans
les prochaines années pas raconter
d'histoire donc ce cadre là il est fichu
il faut le mettre à la poubelle il faut
le repenser il faut pas leur pensée
uniquement en bougeant les curseurs à la
hausse on va pas dire à ben maintenant
on va dire que le déficit c'est cissé la
dette c'est 120 et ça ira très bien non
faut repenser encore une fois la nature
de la dépense moi j'aimerais qu'en
europe on est cette capacité
d'investissement commun on l'a démontré
à travers la crise avec le plan de
relance j'aimerais que cela serve de
base politique pour la suite avec la
présidence française à l'union
européenne qui pourrait servir justement
de fer de lance dans cette dynamique là
pfff et puis nous devons repenser la
dépense de fonctionnement là où la
france est en retard et faut le dire et
ça va demander un travail difficile de
réforme c'est que sur le déficit qu'on
appelle le structurel hors crise or
conjoncture la wii la france est
toujours en retard et n'a pas assez
équilibré ses dépenses publiques mais je
me permets de préciser que s'il ya une
majorité qui a su baisser la dépense
publique qui a su réduire l'endettement
entre 2017 et 2020 c'est celle ci c'est
celle d' emmanuel macron les autres
majorité précédente avait
systématiquement augmenter la dette
augmenter le déficit hors crise nous
nous sommes restés sous les 3% et il
faut rappeler que la procédure de
déficit excessif européenne a été enfin
terminée sous cette mandature c'est en
2018 on va essayer de pas être trop
technique parce que ce budget il est
quand même technique évidemment c'est un
budget mais mais d'abord un petit point
quand même sur une méthode il ya des
dépenses importantes qui ne sont pas
dans ce budget c'est ce qui est pointée
par l'opposition c'est ce qui est
pointée par le conseil des finances
publiques notamment la question du
revenu d'engagement pour la jeunesse et
2 milliards le plan d'investissement
dont vous parliez c'est 30 milliards
est-ce que réintroduire ces mesures par
amendement ça vous semble une bonne
méthode pour étudier un budget écoutez
le calendrier constitutionnel de loi de
finances est ainsi fait que si un objet
politique n'est pas arbitré comme on dit
techniquement c'est à dire que si tout
n'est pas prêt vous le présentez par
voie d'amendement plutôt que dans le
texte initial maintenant ce que les
français veulent savoir c'est pas de
savoir si c'est dans le texte du conseil
des ministres par voie d'amendement je
crois que la grande majorité s'en
fichent pas mal ce qui compte s comme
ces deux parlementaires disent c'est
compliqué pour nous d'étudier un budget
à trous ce qu'il faut c'est que le débat
ait lieu au parlement et il aura lieu et
j'ai exigé du gouvernement que ce débat
devait avoir lieu en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale ça oui ça c'est le
respect de la représentation nationale
qui est en jeu mais franchement je
préfère un revenu d'engagement près bien
finalisés qui trouve sa cible et qu'ils
soient prêtes à l'emploi dès 2022 par
voie d'amendement plutôt quelque chose
de bâclé qui trouvera jamais sa cible
parce qu'il faut absolument finir de
l'écrire deux semaines avant soyons un
petit peu raisonnable je sais qu'on est
dans l'ère de l'immédiateté permanente
mais enfin il faut attendre que quelque
chose soit arbitré avant de le présenter
au parlement ça me semble quand même que
justement le revenu l'engagement est ce
quelque chose qui va coûter cher les
jeux ne le vende pas tous forcément
aujourd'hui la difficulté ça semble
plutôt de pourvoir pour l'emploi dit un
million d'emplois bon est-ce qu'il est
toujours nécessaire comme il l'était il
ya un an précisément parce qu'il ya des
secteurs en tension au niveau des
ressources humaines que le revenu
d'engagement a aussi du sens revenus
d'engagement c'est pas une allocation
c'est pas une allocation sait comment
est-ce qu'on poursuit un meilleur
accompagnement des jeunes notamment mais
l'enjeu est plus intergénérationnel que
ça ce ne sont pas que les jeunes l'idée
ce n'est pas de faire la garantie jeunes
avec plus de bénéficiaires uniquement il
va falloir que y ait une vraie réflexion
sur la formation au delà de revenus
d'engagement pour que les métiers en
tension puisse trouver des candidats
rapidement ça ce sont des sujets que
nous avions déjà avant la crise auquel
nous avions commencé à répondre
notamment par les réformes sur la
formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage qui marche très bien il
ya plus apprenti pendant la crise
qu'avant la crise rendez vous compte du
succès de ces mesures c'est formidable
de se dire quand même que enfin en a
réussi ce pari de l'apprentissage en
france et encore beaucoup à faire vous
avez raison il ya beaucoup de jeunes
éloignés de l'emploi et beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont en déshérence dans notre
pays et il ya aussi beaucoup de filières
qui recherchent de métier donc oui il
faut absolument mettre en face cette
offre est cette demande de l'emploi
particulièrement sur la jeunesse mais
pas que leur vu d'engagements y répondra
en partie mais c'est un travail de
structures là aussi plus profond on va
parler du reste de l'actualité ces
mesures annoncées hier par jean castex
pour les personnes âgées majeur sur la
dépendance sur l'autonomie 400 millions
dont un plancher horaires pour les aides
à domicile des emplois aussi promis du
recrutement dans les ehpad emmanuel
macron il avait promis grande loi
d'autonomie et de la dépendance elle ne
verra pas le jour d'ici la fin du
quinquennat ce que ça va rester comme un
échec ne vas te crées là là encore nous
sommes sur public sénat c'est normal que
nous parlions de loi mais attention pour
nos concitoyens ce qui compte c'est de
voir ce qui change ce qui va être
proposé dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale etc a
été annoncée par le premier ministre ce
sont des avancées concrètes concrètes
pour nos concitoyens oui l'enjeu de la
dépendance l'enjeu de l'autonomie c'est
un enjeu majeur de notre société nous
l'avons toujours dit nous avons puisque
vous parlez de loi je vous le rappelle
créer cet historique la cinquième manche
dans notre pays nous avons créé la
cinquième bourges nous avons commencé à
la finance et 715 euros là nous allons
plus loin avec effectivement des moyens
financiers pour une certain nombre de
catégories de populations qui sont dans
cette situation là et puis leur
entourage et puis demain il faudra
effectivement finaliser ce travail là
autour d'une grande loi autonomie qui
devra notamment réfléchir sur le
financement pérenne de la notion
d'autonomie et de cette fameuse
il faudra je crois que c'est
indispensable mais encore une fois nous
sommes à l'ère de l'immédiateté nous
voudrions que tout soit réglé en
quelques jours la sécurité sociale de
cette famille depuis longtemps pour lui
mais la sécurité sociale
à 4 heures nous parlons là d'un pan de
notre société qui est immense où chacun
d'entre nous est concernée d'une manière
directe ou indirecte
donc c'est normal que cela prenne du
temps tu là encore c'est du dialogue
avec le pays qui est nécessaire on peut
pas à la fois toujours nous reprocher
une présidence du pit aryenne brutale
verticale et quand nous faisons les
choses par étapes nous dire que nous
sommes trop long c'est pas possible il
faut choisir sa bataille nous
est ce que la cinquième manche a été
créé la réponse est oui est ce que nous
mettons les moyens pour une autonomie
mieux encadrer mieux prises en charge la
réponse est oui est ce que demain il
faudra probablement finalisée ce
travail-là par un mécanisme de
financement une loi qui lui a fait
rentrer probablement oui aussi nous
avançons nous n'avons jamais laisser ce
dossier en jachère autres
oui la crise ou bien alors la réaction
de la france at elle été à la hauteur on
a quand même senti un peu une gêne de ne
pas vouloir couper tous les ponts avec
nos amis américains
vous savez
les relations internationales c'est pas
le débat mélenchon zemmour les relations
internationales c'est pas twitter les
relations internationales c'est sérieux
ça demande du temps ça demande de la
réflexion de la consultation entre
alliés avec d'autres pays et de prendre
des décisions qui s'imposent ça prend du
temps et j'ai observé avec intérêt
citoyens comment le pays commenté le
silence entre guillemets du président de
la république pendant ces jours ci alors
quand est-ce qu'il va parler pourquoi il
parle pas mais ce n'est pas une cour de
récré on se chamaille pas comme cela
nous avons été trahis par nos pays
alliés dans cette histoire ce n'est pas
rien c'est une très grave crise la
réponse
elle n'est pas du berger à la bergère
c'est pas un oeil pour oeil dent pour
dent la réponse elle se fait de façon
intelligente dans les intérêts de la
france et de l'europe c'est que ça qui
compte dans la tête du président de la
république
sion la réaction défendant emmanuel
macron sur quasiment tous les sujets là
vous le dit la france a été trahie but
est ce que le président de la république
française n'aurait pas dû s'exprimer et
parler aux français l'elysée a mis un
communiqué que vous avez lu après les
changes que le président a eu avec le
président biden qui démontre quand même
que les etats unis reconnaissent
reconnaissent ce qui s'est passé ce qui
n'est pas fréquent
prendre les sous marins car l'histoire
des relations internationales regardez
les mots c'est pas tous les jours
par ailleurs que les états unis viennent
accompagner le travail de la france
notamment au sahel
c'est une avancée considérable
par ailleurs le fait que demain nous
devrons repenser nos relations
atlantique parce qu'il est temps de
comprendre que la france pour reprendre
les la bonne expression de gabriella
talent ne cherche pas un grand frère
mais cherche un partenaire je crois
qu'ils l'ont compris donc nous sortirons
de cette crise trail et avec un contrat
commercial raté c'est vrai mais nous
sortirons de cette crise avec des
relations atlantique je le crois repensé
et où on aura remis si on me passez
l'expression l'église au milieu du
village et ça c'est une bonne chose
l'autre sujet qui préoccupe les français
c'est bien sûr cette crescent heures il
n'y aura un le pass and i télé les ondes
eggers jusqu'au 15 novembre avoir un
projet de loi en conseil des ministres
mi octobre pour le prolonger ce pas
salutaire il faut prolonger jusqu'à
quand pour vous écoutez je ne dis pas de
date à vous donner ce qui est sûr c'est
que le pass annie terre est un succès
c'est un succès la preuve tous les pays
le dise je vais la suisse récemment
s'exprimer à ce sujet là des pays qui
n'ont pas souvent coutume de dire que ce
que fait la france est formidable et oui
on peut être fier collectivement ce pas
une question de majorité ce pas une
question politique on peut être fier
collectivement d'avoir trouvé la réponse
qui nous a permis de ne pas refermer le
pays
ce que tout le monde voulait le passé ni
terre ça marche c'est rapide tout le
monde s'en félicite tant qu'il sera
nécessaire je crois qu'il est de bon
aloi de le conserver mais j'étais à la
question est ce qu'il faut aller les
élections que le plus à nouveau je n'ai
pas deux mais qu'il faut aller après les
élections et ce qu'il faut repasser par
le parlement avant avant la match je
n'ai pas de date à vous donner ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il y aura un débat au
parlement très prochainement là dessus
je vous donne ma philosophie le pass
annie terre ça marche ça marche ça
permet au pays de rester vivant on a
presque une vie normale on a presque une
vie normale c'est ça la bataille gagnée
c'est ça la bataille gagnée la
vaccination en a réussi un taux de
vaccination exceptionnellement haut
c'était un pari on l'a réussi sénateurs
socialistes il aller plus loin ils
veulent la vaccination les
écouter philosophiquement pourquoi pas
mais c'est quoi la vaccination
obligatoire moi je suis décideurs
publics j'agis pour que les choses aient
lieu dans mon pays c'est quoi la
vaccination obligatoire vous ne voulez
pas monsieur jalabert vous faire
vacciner qu'est ce que j'ai fait qu'est
ce que je fais je vous mets des menottes
je vous amène qu'est ce que c'est la
vaccination obligatoire moi je préfère
le dialogue la persuasion la conviction
donc oui sur le ici et si nous avons dû
nous avons dépassé les 50 millions de
primo vacciner c'est quand même que la
vaccination par la force de pédagogie et
de persuasion ça marche un dernier mot
sur ce sujet vous avez entendu sûrement
question mme taubira hier elle elle
refuse d'appeler à la vaccination en
guyane elle dit qu'elle ne dispose pas
assez d'éléments d'information qui lui
permettrait de donner des consignes
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ces
propos je les ai trouvés irresponsable
parce que c'est trop facile de dire j'ai
une super responsabilités j'ai pas me
prononcer la vaccination je suis désolé
c'est un sujet de tout le monde est un
sujet de société et quand on a été
ancien ministre ancien responsable de
premier plan politique et que montre
parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
21 mis trop au micro de rtl une défiance
dans la science est finalement laissé
planer un doute sur la nécessité de se
vacciner personnellement je trouve ça
irresponsable et madame taubira pour qui
j'avais le plus grand respect tout d'un
coup en quelques secondes s'est rangé
dans le camp des florian philippot
martin vos nerfs des sceptiques et des
anti vaccins je trouve que c'est
dangereux parce que sa parole elle a du
poids notamment à gauche et que si
certaines personnes pouvaient encore
hésiter à se faire vacciner je trouve
que son influence négative et dangereuse
est coupable pour notre pays hier soir
il y avait un débat entre
jean luc mélenchon et le potentiel
candidat de droite nationale eric
zemmour comptent ils eu raison de
débattre j'ai eu un choc il bien fait
d'aller à ce débat sur le principe vous
savez moi je suis libéral
il faut toujours débattre plutôt que
ignorer ce qui de toute façon existe
comme l'idée dans un pays donc sur le
principe je reproche pas monsieur
mélenchon d'être aller débattre c'est
quoi et massa rugueuse et mourra les
jours c'est la réaction c'est une france
fantasmé qui n'a jamais existé la france
d'eric zemmour telle qu'il la dcri n'a
jamais existé c'est ça france fantasmée
et
c'est surtout au delà de quelques items
récurrent que sont l'immigration l'islam
les musulmans
pour moi une incompétence crasse dans un
grand nombre de domaines de l'action
publique qui font qu'aujourd'hui et
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il
hésite il n'a pas l'étoffé d'un candidat
et encore moins le futur président de la
république
que jean luc mélenchon ils débattent sur
le fond sur les idées c'est son choix
pour tout vous dire j'ai pas regardé
hier soir inauguré un centre culturel
dans ma circonscription et les gens
étaient beaucoup plus heureux je crois
que devant leur poste de télévision ont
du coup j'imagine qu'on n'avait pas non
plus regarder le débat
avait lieu au même moment valérie
peisson je regardais en replay alors
c'est votre président de région contre l
original qu'est ce que
je respecte la candidature de valérie
pécresse après pour l'instant ils sont
dans sa match de personnes je remarque à
chaque fois qu'un match de personnes ça
prend beaucoup de temps et l'espace sur
le match des idées donc pour l'instant
je n'ai pas très bien compris ni hier
soir d'ailleurs quels étaient les idées
que proposait madame pécresse pourquoi
faire les choses
qu'on avait quand même l'impression que
sur beaucoup de points il était d'accord
concernant les questions posées création
mais on peut être d'accord sur certains
points en politique heureusement
heureusement est d'ailleurs le
dépassement des clivages que nous avons
fait avec emmanuel macron rend logique
le fait que amin'izay l'intérieur venant
des républicains est encore des points
communs avec une femme politique venant
des républicains cela n'a rien choquant
et d'ailleurs pose plutôt des
incohérences vers ce qui pour exister
politiquement
et c'est d'aller de plus en plus vers
les extrêmes mais c'est un autre c'est
un autre débat
valérie pécresse si l'ensemble des
candidats de la primaire de la droite a
l'impression qu'elle va de plus en plus
vers les extrêmes valérie pécresse avait
dit je vous rappelle pendant la campagne
pour les régionales
qu'il y avait un trait d'union direct
entre terrorisme et l'immigration pardon
mais c'est pas madame pécresse dia
disant ça s'était plutôt madame le pen
ou monsieur ciotti qui disait ça bon
donc j'observe rinne dérive sémantique
idéologique de la part mais pas que de
madame pécresse monsieur barnier sur
l'immigration tient des propos et
notamment sur l'europe qu'il n'aurait
pas tenu il ya six mois donc je connais
la politique je veux bien qu'il y ait
pour le match présidentielle pour le
match interne et pour séduire ses
électeurs parfois quelques tactiques
dans les mots bien sûr mais enfin ça a
ses limites ça a ses limites à un moment
c'est dangereux pour le pays quand
l'ensemble des partis dits républicains
fleurs de plus en plus avec les thèses
extrémistes
oui donc edouard philippe l'ancien
premier ministre aux lois beaucoup ces
derniers temps il veut exister dans la
majorité quelle place pouvez vous lui
confiez
et or philippe et l'ancien premier
ministre des manuels macron c'est le
premier premier ministre de notre
mandature il a été un grand premier
ministre probablement un des meilleurs
de la vème république et il sera un très
grand soutien au président de la
république pour sa réélection si celui
ci venait d'être candidat et pourra
placer à paris-xii la place d'edouard
philippe au centre parce que son rôle
est central en tant que plante je suis
une partie de la droite ne va pas de la
droite de votre majorité on ne va pas
rejoindre edouard philippe et d'acier
qui disait la coupe travaille encore est
ce qu'il n'est pas en train de faire
travailler la poutre au sein de la
majorité présidentielle
mais que veut dire rejoindre edouard
philippe nous sommes tous dans le même
bateau qui celui de faire réélire le
président de la république va créer sa
propre formation politique
ça fait déjà plusieurs formations
politiques vous avez la république en
marche vous avez le modem vous avez
territoire de progrès vous avez agir
vous savez en commun par exemple tout ça
existe déjà je trouve très bien qu
edouard philippe affirme entrer dans
l'arène de la campagne présidence avec
sa propre structure son propre mouvement
et puis j'ai un immense respect pour lui
il apportera beaucoup lui et il faut
regretter l'ensemble des actions
communes avec qui il faut une maison
commune là on n'y voit pas très clair
avec là encore nous sommes sur public
sénat ce sont des considérations
toujours importante la vérité c'est que
nos français veulent savoir ce que le
président de la république a fait pour
eux pendant cinq ans et nous sommes en
train de leur rappeler et il le voit
notamment en termes de pouvoir d'achat
et de progrès économique
et puis ils veulent surtout savoir
interviendra en son temps je l'espère ce
que le président de la république a
alors proposé pour les cinq prochaines
années l'intérieur savoir si c'est une
boutique cinq boutiques pour l'ensemble
des français je vous assure c'est bien
secondaire et merci vous remercie
notre invité ce matin merci pascal
jalabert ont face au club des
territoires
[Musique]